[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi i'm with the pr team at wolfram uh
today i'm talking with senior software
engineer
todd reichert we're going to talk a
little bit about parsing user agent
values with the wolfram language how you
doing todd
good how are you excellent uh so i
i did look up uh this user agent value
concept
and you can actually go to
whatismybrowser.com
they'll give you your user agent and i
will admit that i looked at it and
it was total nonsense um so with that in
mind
could you explain just a little bit
about this uh this whole user agent
value thing and
how it works into your workflow great
yeah so i'll go ahead and jump into my
presentation or my slideshow
yeah so yeah let's see so
so the background is yeah
the the user agent field project
or side project that i kind of started
here
came from doing web log analysis um
i i highly suspect most people ignore
this field
because of its complexity and storied
past
um yeah if you research it on the
internet you know
it's it's a fun little read for five
minutes if you need a brain drop
um but yeah it's it's so really just
kind of came out of this thing that was
like i
i can't decipher this field i didn't
know i didn't know what it was at the
time
so i just kind of ignored it i put it
off to the side saved it put it off to
the side
and when i'm i'm gonna i'll i'll
research it you know after i kind of get
get my things you know get my other
larger scale projects set up and so
when i came back to this you know this
is you know
i found this field and i did a little
researching and
didn't turn away right away you know
going ooh this sounds
icky you know it doesn't sound useful um
but you know i
i decided to do a little research and um
uh i'll let me skip forward here for
just one second
the i actually asked around the company
and i found out that they used
this uh project um we'll we'll skip
we'll go backwards now um
a a user agent field looks like what i
have bolded here
right you know i mean you can kind of
see some things you're like mozilla
windows gecko fire you know you don't
know
uh you know you could probably try to
figure out some things you could write
your own way to kind of try to extract
this information but um whenever i found
out
how many user agent values i got like 80
000 different types of user agent things
i was like okay that's
not a regular expression i'm really
willing to write
yeah that's real so um the user agent
field
at its core is supposed to provide
browser operating system and des
and device information um doesn't always
include all of those um as we see with
this particular example here it is
supposedly indicates that it's a
firefox browser a windows os
and no no device information so
so it's so it's sort of just sporadic as
to
what type what like what not only what
type of information but sort of how it's
displayed is that correct
uh the the i i think if
you know once again i apologize i didn't
overly read
uh the context but yes it it it's
supposed to be in a structured format
but what what what i basically
gleaned from reading all this stuff was
people
well internet explorer needed to
circumvent some issues it was having so
it would start putting mozilla in the
front of everything
i'm probably summarizing a little you
know
poorly there but it's you know it it was
a
it's a field that almost everybody puts
mozilla in the front of it
okay okay to get a certain certain level
of feed because
what what happened was browsers wouldn't
do things unless you were this
right so a lot of people wanted
wanted things to happen in certain
browsers so they would
fib a little and say they were and so
so it it it's yeah it's it
it's a fun little field you know um i
i i'm from my analysis
you know i'm i'm only getting about 20
to 30 percent hits
probably okay of a valid type
user agents because anybody can send any
user
user agent so i'm highly suspect there's
a lot of people that
obfuscate their user agent field you
know because
okay so but you know whenever you're
talking about
20 or 30 percent of hundreds of
thousands
you know that that's that's still got
some value you know it's still got you
know
it's still a chance that that's really a
good snapshot of
of what people are you know what
browsers operating systems and devices
people are using so
sure sure yeah it at least gives you a
little bit more data
in an area that you might not have had
it before so yeah
yep so so yeah so i i you know like say
if
after the fact i you know i i done all
this um
uh web web analysis you know project
got it all working came back to this
user agent um
you know got intrigued enough because
you know as programmers we
enjoy a challenge um and so
that's whenever i i asked around i was
like hey guys what what are you using
well people
told me that they were using this github
project ua parser
and as i researched that particular
project
i realized that they had done a pretty
good design
that they had actually moved to the
regular expressions
into a file and then they had a lot of
implementations
of use of that regular expressions file
like a java
python you know etc and then in between
that data and the implementations
was is a spec that these implementations
have to follow so
um i researched the spec
um i believe that's uh well it's it's
it's two slides down
um and i i researched that spec
and was like i i i'm pretty for sure
wolfram language could could do this
um you know and so i i i decided to
you know to take a stab at it um read
the spec
understand the date this regular
expression i sometimes refer to it as a
data file
um and and take a run at doing a wolf
from language implementation
so that's that was kind of my
you know if if i couldn't get the
wolfram language implementation to work
i was probably going to fall back to
this project and you know research
you know how the other teams were using
it and
you know create a web service and access
it that way but
you know i was wanting to do something
local a little faster so
so if you unless you don't have any
questions we'll dig into this
uh well i i have a feeling you're
probably going to cover it but
i was curious just because uh wolfram
language will
actually do regex like regular
expressions
in a in basically the same way i think
as as other systems
that's one way to do pattern matching in
the wolfram language
but then there is the actual pattern
language that's built into
the wolfram language so i'm just curious
did you
did you use the regular expressions or
did you create
your own wolfram patterns for this uh i
i used we could probably speak at the
code here um
i i just i what was so
amazing to me was i was able
if we peek at the file here that that
that that's a regular expression
so right here is a regular expression i
was able to just to plop that in
as a dynamic variable within a code
i didn't have to do any you know so so
you know part of this effort would have
been greatly
put to the side if if i was going to
have to
modify this value too much i was able to
just
take this field i think i do have to
escape one character it's maybe the open
print i forget which one it is
i think i have to escape one character
one character in this
string and and and then it just it
matches
so i mean i i didn't have to
you know that i i was able to concoct
some more from language code
that just took this thing in and matched
and it just worked
yeah so yeah i i was highly impressed
you know if
if like say if i would have had to mess
with this value
my i may have i may have but but i
didn't so
happy path um so
so just uh just to i
i i want to explain this file just a
little bit just to let people know
you know the the that the wolfram
language was able to handle the
the complexity of this this little file
so
so this file this data file this
regular expression file that was from
this this github project
on ua parser is divided into three
section a browser and os and a device
um and then within each section there's
reg x's you know regular expressions but
then each regular expression
could have overrides or replacements
they call them
so so if if we peek at
a browser parser here you know this is a
regex um
so what you're looking at here is these
two parens
create what's called a slot and so
this this would be slot one slot two um
on down the path and so that's how i
know how to pull
information out of this so in this
particular situation
this would probably be the browser you
know
which okay may or may not make any sense
but like if you go down here
the family replacement so i
i you you can go read the spec and
figure out all that but basically this
this means that when this is found
that you you replace the family
slot with this so
you know it there there's additional
complexity within these
regular expressions that you know
everything below a regular expression
could be a replacement or an override
yeah so you know these are what os
um section is the os section looks like
um and then the device section here
you know so um you know
fun fun stuff if you're into that sort
of thing
yeah yeah it's uh it's interesting to
try and sort of read what what those
uh expressions are doing um yeah i've
always i've always found it kind of
interesting i'm not very good at it
myself
um but i do i do think the uh regular
expressions are pretty
pretty cool honestly yes yeah so
so you know you'd probably maybe you
have a quick
quick question of like well why would
you have replacements well it's because
you know everything between here and
here you know you're saying it could it
could be this
or this or this or this or this so you
know so everything
here you know so that this captures
the the value for you and then this lets
you
say you know what even though we've
captured this string
i really want to you know make it say
this so so
so those overrides were a little bit of
fun so
add a little bit of complexity so
um so that was that that that's the data
file so
if we'll talk about the my
implementation here
um this this particular link here will
take you to the
spec um um so feel free to go
enjoy that if you would like um and
so jump into there's only a few few
pieces of code here
um this is just a little helper function
i i needed to have
to um help with extracting the
uh the the regex
out of that file but ultimately
right here um this is where i you know
once again one of the neat things about
wolfram language
this command right here goes out to the
internet and grabs
grabs the most current version of that
file for me
great does it um i had to do a little
bit of trickery because there's
there's so many crazy characters in that
file i had to
do a little bit more trickery than i
would have liked but ultimately you know
i just have to do this little little
piece of code here to
clean the clean the data that's being
pulled through here through here and
then
you know that file you know goes into
what i
extract into there um
this one this particular function here
so so now that i have the
file um this this particular
function here gets me the the three
different sections
so i i can ask for a specific section
out of that um and this is this is where
it gets a little tricky because this is
where you have to um be
mindful of all those slots and this is
where the spec
this is where you know this is where you
you do the
you implement the spec of you know they
say if you if this happens do this if
this happens do this so
um you know so it's it's it it could
look intimidating but you know it's it's
actually wasn't that bad so see this is
where i
get get that that regex file
shove it through there and that's
that that gets me my that gives me the
ability to request a certain section of
the file
um this this this particular function
here takes a
a user agent and then gets and then is
also past
one of those sections that we got out of
there and then tries to do the match
um once again could look kind of
intimidating but
really the the complexity comes in the
spec not the wolfram language code
right um and then this this particular
this is kind of the wrapper that wraps
it all up for us
um you pass you just pass in that that
regular or that user agent field
um and it goes out and you know
get gets the info gets the browser info
gets the
os the device using that function
mentioned above
and then here here the the the point the
point of this
i would highlight this for everybody is
this is really whatever you want it to
be
if you don't care about os or device
information you just care about browser
you know so this is really giving you
the ability in this particular situation
um you know this was how i wanted the
the data formatted on the way out
um so um you know this is
uh i i initially developed
a prototyped it in a notebook then i
pulled it over to the server
slightly tweaked it for that and then
whenever i pulled it in for this
particular
demo here i um you know had to tweak it
again a little bit for
just readability that's that's all the
code
um for something fairly complex i would
think
um you know but but the complexity came
from that spec not not not from the
wolfram language so
right right so that's that's the code do
you have any
i can i i'm just curious if uh
the the amount of detail that you're
extracting there in terms of
you know the version numbers and um the
details
about the operating system is that
basically the maximum amount of detail
that you can get
yes well according to this project so
you know there's other people that have
obviously in my research
for this um you know there's other
companies that do but really all
it's it's a fairly what we used to call
a brute brute force method basically
it's it's hand curated you know it's
just people
um taking the time to do this you know
that's you know and so
this this this particular project is
fairly active
um so i'm you know i'm confident that
the people are going to keep
updating it um i i
didn't learn i i'll
be careful saying this i i didn't i
didn't learn
a lot about the the detail of the field
um okay you know i i learned
you know how to you know implement this
regular expression and run this
run this thing up against you know i i
you know the the people that would dig
into these specific values
you know i you know in
a lot of times in in the enterprise
world
you know you you don't have time to yeah
uh
to spend you know becoming an expert in
something
and so i i think this this was a good
example to show
how well from language can be used in in
that environment where
you're doing something rapid um you know
you don't have to understand something
so deeply you know you know but but you
you can get immediate value so
what i always say is kind of return of
investment you know you get you get good
return of investment
out of this pretty quickly um you know
and
and you know i'm able to move on to
other things so
right right and like you said you know
other people have done the legwork on
that it's
it's yeah a fairly reliable project so
uh
yeah it's convenient that you can just
integrate it pretty quickly and
get a result yeah and like and and this
was
you know like say for the fact that
wolfram language
the majority of my time spent was
understanding that spec
so that has nothing to do with wolfram
language so yeah um
so to push on here you know i just have
five examples here of um
some user agents and i don't know if you
remember that
that was the name of that last function
we looked at
so user agents that's that variable we
just looked at up here
you know it's an it's an array of five
five user agents we pass that
you know through this loop into that
function and then we
use data set to display here pretty
pretty simple
you know that this is what's really nice
of you know about
you know wolfram language is you know
you can get these nice looking
uh displays here pretty quickly um we'll
just
look at this one here you know so you
know from that user agent lookup
you know we were able to get all this
information pretty quickly
um the second one here actually has a
device on it so
um like i say i i i twisted the code a
little bit here
but you know it wasn't that girthy for
the amount of information that we pulled
in
um you know from that that regex file
and to get that information that quickly
you know
within a notebook you know um so yeah so
that's
that's that so um
yeah so yeah did you
i i see you've got some final thoughts
here yeah so
um yeah so like i i
will from language uh i i probably
might my approach was i'm just going to
work on just the regular expressions and
not the
um uh the replacement values i got that
up and running
within a day um you know the the
you know understanding how to get the
data matching you know and
so that that was just great you know the
the next day was spent
you know trying to figure out how to do
those except exception
cases the replacements and things like
that so wolfram language you know that
that was a great example of that um uh
this this particular situation here you
know
web services exists for this but this
this became local
which is much preferable by a lot of
enterprises don't
like that you know they they like to
stay is
stay behind behind their firewall as
much as possible
of course um and because well from
language once again does does
some things very nicely like calling out
to the internet that this
this repo is always up to date you know
without a lot of work we didn't have to
worry about that
um so yeah so beyond the scope
um you know we as we said we were able
to call it to the internet and then just
be able to
just be able to do awesome things with
that data quickly the regular expression
matching as i alluded to earlier the
fact that that
that data file just plopped right into
wolfram language code
and just worked can't beat that
um and how to package up your results
for easy consumption that was that part
i highlighted at the end just how easy
it was that you know now we have this
data you
you can deliver it however you want um
um i i think one other thing i would
like to add here too is
i i think what what what i also would
like for people to blur their eyes a
little bit with this
this concept here this this notebook is
self self contained
right um you know there there's no
pulling in
you know going oh you got to have this
you got to have that this is a
self-contained book
and a notebook and you know
it doesn't have to be user agent values
you know
you know if if if companies can set
things up
appropriately um you know to where
people write notebooks to pull out and
pull in the
the data you know you can start having
people that aren't necessarily
programmers
do things you know in notebooks that are
extremely powerful
and so i i just think you know this this
is just a
another feather in the cap um for
wolfram language
just to show how how fast and easy and
and like say that the code the code
could look intimidating but
it's it's not it's it's um if if you
if you if you build it up slowly you you
actually start to
um feel the feel the power
yeah and i would imagine that uh looking
at other implementations
that use that same uh
that same file that you were looking at
it's probably
i would i would guess the wolfram
language code is is a bit simpler so
yes yeah i i did actually yeah i i did
peek at the
pearl in java um because i'm fairly um
competent in those just to make sure
that i was implementing the spec right
and yeah it was
you know like say i i'm i'm fair you
know there there's obvious there's
always ways to knit
nip and tuck your code or to redesign it
a different way so
i'm not saying the way i did it here was
perfect you know i i leave that as an
exercise to people if if they gain
access to this notebook
to re reinvent it to uh you know there's
probably some glaring uh inefficiencies
but you know
for the sake of this demonstration you
know it was
it was it was what i just pulled
together pretty quick so
all right so uh like you said another
another success for uh wolfram notebooks
and uh the regular expressions and
sort of just being able to get get
things done quickly
uh so anybody out there looking to parse
user agent values or anything
any similar types of uh especially text
uh you heard it here yeah
thanks for thanks for talking to us todd
no problem thank you thank you
thanks for joining us you can check out
other wolfram tech talks live coding
streams and more on the wolfram research
youtube channel
or see what else is new at wolfram.com
you